JAMES CLEWETT: The end
is nigh, Brady.
Time is coming to an end, and
I can tell you, actually,
precisely when time
is going to end.
It's going to end at 3:00 AM,
3:14.07 on the 19th of
January, 2038.
What's going on is we're
talking about
the end of Unix time.
Now--
BRADY HARAN: What's that?
JAMES CLEWETT: You're making a
face at me like you don't know
what I'm talking about, Brady.
Most of us at home are using
either Windows or Mac-based
operating systems for
our computers.
And somewhere buried deep down
inside that system is a little
counter that's been ticking
away every second--
that's a fast second--
every second since
January 1, 1970.
They began a counter in a 32-bit
number, crucially, that
was just going to
count seconds.
And obviously, because it's
only a 32-bit number, it's
going to run out
at some point.
That is the point.
This is the moment when
that number runs out
of seconds to count.
This is how your computer
is telling the time.
is keeping the date.
So you can take this number, the
number of seconds, and you
can divide it and keep dividing
it and keep dividing
it to get back to the number of
minutes, hours, days, years
that have passed since
January 1, 1970.
So, this is what's cool
with the Unix Epoch.
Now the reason I keep talking
about Unix is because way back
then, there was this operating
system called Unix, which was
just beginning to really take
a hold in corporations and
really mission critical
systems.
The point is, in every single
one of those mission critical
machines, there's a number
ticking away, counting the
seconds, and it's ticking
towards January the 19th,
2038, when it's going
to run out.
And when it does, a very weird
thing is going to happen.
It's going to roll back to--
I think it's December 1901.
So, in some ways, it's great,
because it's an opportunity
for us to redo the 20th
century and maybe get
it right this time.
But in other ways, it's going to
be absolutely catastrophic,
cause it's a lot like the
Millennium Bug--so some of
your viewers were too young to
remember the Millennium Bug.
But those of us that were there,
the Millennium bug was
a problem when we were storing
the date as a two-digit number
in a lot of computers mostly
back in the '80s.
And everybody thought,
it's a long way away.
We're not going to have to worry
about what happens when
we get to 2000.
But it just turns out that once
you've got a computer
that works, say if you're in a
bank or if you're running an
airline, you have a
system that works.
It costs too much to bother
changing that, so things get
left just working for years
and years and years.
And it came up to 2000 and all
of these computers were just
going to fail in some
obscure way.
So a lot of the time the date
started showing as 19,100, or
if it was a system which was
dependent on the incremental
date, like it's adding interest
to your bank account,
then suddenly it was going to
go from being 99 to being 0.
And it was going to add a huge
amount of negative interest to
your bank account, which is good
if you've got a mortgage
and terrible if you've
got savings.
I worked on this for a few
years leading up to the
millennium, and we went around
and we fixed all of the
machines that were too old to
survive the millennium.
And of course, everybody
knows it wasn't a
problem in the end.
OK, so there were a few cases,
some sad cases and some quite
funny cases where it did go
wrong, but for the most part,
it wasn't a problem.
So, we have to go back to the
Pac-Man video that we did
where we were talking about
binary numbers.
And in Pac-Man, we were storing
that binary number as
an 8-bit binary value, and that
meant that it could count
up to a maximum of 256.
Now, it's a choice.
It's either a maximum of 256
and a minimum of 0, or a
minimum of minus 128 and
a maximum of 127.
So, this value has been running
from a minimum of
minus 2 billion to a maximum of
plus 2 billion, and this is
the moment when it reaches that
maximum value of 2 billion.
Well, it's not actually
2 billion.
It's about 2,150,000,000.
But it's a big number.
BRADY HARAN: When I turn my
computer off at home and it
hasn't got electricity,
obviously it's not counting
anymore, is it?
JAMES CLEWETT: It's not counting
anymore, but there is
a battery inside, which is
storing its current state.
So it depends on how your
computer's set up.
Some computers are set up to
connect immediately to the
server and get the current time
just to make sure that
all of those computers are
synchronized across the network.
Other computers, like your home
computer, are set up just
to read the date or the time
from a memory chip, which has
been keeping its store
with a CMOS battery.
What we're going to have to
do, very simply-- same
solution as always with these
things-- we've got to throw
away the machines which have
got two small a number and
replace them with
bigger version.
And that's already beginning
to happen.
We're already moving from 32-bit
computers, which count
in 32-bit numbers, to 64-bit
computers, which count in
64-bit numbers.
And with a 64-bit counter, then
this problem is pushed
out an awfully long way, and
actually that number is
somewhere way beyond the end
of the known universe.
Way beyond the heat death
of the universe.
BRADY HARAN: Is it going to
be a date when everyone's
worried, do you think?
Do you think this is going to
be panic stations when this
time comes?
JAMES CLEWETT: Yes.
I think there will
be a problem.
Because I remember being
in a bank in 1999--
quite a long time ago now--
and looking at the oldest
computer I had ever seen, and
somebody saying, oh, that's
just our payment system.
And it just worked.
They used that word-- just--
and nobody had ever
thought about it.
And I had to look at that
machine and say, well, you
know what, your payment
system's not going
to work next week.
We need to fix that.
And I don't doubt for a second
that there will be 32-bit
computers sitting in the corner
of some dusty bank
building, society, or airline
or whatever in 2038, and
they're going to
just go wrong.
And all of those bookings for
your holiday in Malaga are all
going to be erased in
some horrible way.
So I don't think it's going
to go wrong in any
life-threatening manner, but,
yeah, there will be some
comical errors.
And certainly for people like
me who know how to fix this
problem, there's a great
opportunity to--
well, this is my pension we're
talking about here.
I'm going to go around upgrading
32-bit computers to
64-bit computers to pay for the
last 30 years of my life.
I'm looking forward
to it already.
You can go through and
you can pick out key
dates in Unix numbers.
The 9th of September, 2001, was
one billion, and quite a
few people celebrated that.
There was a small celebration
in Norway for 1,111,111,111.
And so people are noticing
Unix time ticking away.
But for most of us, it's
happening behind our backs.
So, what we have here
is the current Unix
time at 1.34 billion.
So if you're feeling really
smart at home, apart from the
fact of the date's in the top
corner of the screen, you
could work out when we're
actually filming this.
Because this is the number
that the computer uses to
calculate this date.
It's like watching your life
just ticking away.